si aisément direction cannes et avant de
parler cinéma les coulisses du festival
avec ce soir un coup de projecteur sur
les hommes de sécurité les gardes du
corps qui protègent vous allez le voir
les stars mais pas seulement
françois jullien pieds-noirs et mathias
barrois sur place
ils font partie du décor mais ce n'est
pas du cinéma
les gardes du corps sont les acteurs
essentiels d'un bon festival sans
anicroche j'ai quelqu'un en face qui va
attaquer avec un couteau
je vois qu'il ya quelqu'un hop je plaide
non vip autres cas fréquent un fan trop
collant une clé n'est discrète et le
client libéré ça y est je lâche le
dégage merci au revoir et je continue
dont on est à fond agresser les gens on
n'est pas là pour se taper sur les gens
on est là pour anticiper les dangers
certains de ces hommes sont d'anciens
membres des forces spéciales sauf
dérogation ils ne portent pas d'armes
mais une tenue impeccable qui supporte
pas un parfum de leurs agents de
sécurité alors des fois ça peut poser
problème
on s'adapte aux vicois vip very
important personality ce n'est pas la
seule mission de protection de ces
hommes pays entre 50 et 300 euros de
l'heure dans cette sacoche en signifiant
qu'il ya ce qu'ils appellent des
documents pour ne pas dire des bijoux
d'une valeur inestimable
prêté aux célébrités les bijoux ont
aussi leur poser car il n'y a pas que
les vannes c'est surtout la perte qui
nous fait peur car c
c'est vraiment la folie à l'extraction
et stark paires d'oreilles
ça peut arriver c'est déjà arrivé alors
ce soir deux hommes vont suivre devon
aoki cette actrice américaine avec un
oeil non pas sur sa beauté mais sur les
boucles d'oreilles les bijoux vont
monter les marches sous haute protection
je me demandais monsieur si je tombe
d'un immeuble vous venez me sauver où
vous vous occupez des bijoux mois à
instant crucial
les quelques mètres sur le tapis rouge
le garde du corps ne peut pas monter la
star est alors seul même si le monde
entier la regarde
oh mon dieu elle a fait tomber quelque
chose une boucle d'oreille peut-être
non fausse alerte l'objet précieux est
encore là en haut des marches
le garde du corps récupère à l'actrice
et surtout les bijoux et on reste aac